c'est une nouvelle étape pour
l'opération d'aménagement et
d'élargissement de la rd 30
après plus d'un an de travaux cet
ouvrage reliant plaisir à elancourt est
opérationnel coût des travaux 2,3
millions d'euros financés par la région
et le département cette passerelle
permet de favoriser les circulations
douces c'est bien la démonstration qu'on
peut favoriser toutes les mobilités dans
un département qui a par définition une
dominante voiture puisque pour aller
d'un point à l'autre des yvelines les
transports en commun sont insuffisants
c'est bien donc les circulation en
voiture en deux roues et à pied qui
doivent être réglés j'ai démarré en 2015
le chantier de la rd 30 a notamment
permis la mise en service en mars 2018
des deux fois deux voies
aujourd'hui au dessus de la rn12 cette
charpente métallique d'une longueur de
122 m et 5 mètres de large
complètent le maillage cyclable jusqu'au
quartier de la clé saint-pierre à
elancourt depuis plaisir on se rend
compte que non seulement c'était attendu
pour les quartiers plaisir qui sont de
l'autre côté de la nationale mais
également pour relier à montigny sur la
gare et puis aussi pourquoi pas à magny
les hameaux au fin fond de 50 heures ni
vraiment les travaux d'une seconde
passerelle reliant plaisir le bois de la
crâne débuteront à l'automne 2010 9 pour
une livraison attendue en 2020